kanzlerin angela merkel zeigt sich
hinter verschlossenen türen auch sehr
besorgt wie die krone situation hier in
deutschland weitergehen könnte sie
warnte im cdu-präsidium davor dass wir
bald 19.200 neuinfektionen an einem tag
haben könnten
zum vergleich ende märz waren es 3000 an
einem tag aber warum macht die kanzlerin
das warum nennt sie solche schock zahlen
soll es eine warnung sein oder eher
angstmacherei wir haben uns einmal
umgehört was die menschen von angela
merkels aussage halten
wie kommt die dazu das zu sagen sie weiß
es nicht sie kennt unser
gesundheitssystem in deutschland die
weiß wem wie die deutschen inzwischen
drauf sind dass jede maske trägt und
alles und sie kann das nicht mit anderen
ländern vergleichen dir ganz anderes
gesundheitssystem hat und zwar am tag
19.200 das hier sind normales offen
aber wenn sie frau merkel gesagt hat das
muss ja auch stemmen es ist eine neue
ein neuer höhepunkt in der kampagne der
angstmacherei die von den gez medien
anfangen über die meisten zeitungen hin
zur politik das kennen wir jetzt alles
und soll bestimmt damit wieder ein
drüber süppchen gekocht werden so 19.200
neuinfektionen kann mir schon viel vor
für sehr hohe zahl wenn man es auch mit
märz und april vergleicht wobei ich mir
schon vorstellen kann dass es auch
vielleicht mehr wird weil wir jetzt
winter bekommen matschwetter bekommen
der herbst kommt und da steigen ja
eigentlich alle krankheitszahlen immer
an kennung zu 1200 ist meiner meinung
nach ein versprecher von unserer
bundeskanzlerin gestern hatten wir ja um
die 2400 in ganz deutschland ich kann
mir im augenblick nicht vorstellen dass
diese zahl zu erreichen ist wie mir
nicht ganz schlüssig ob man alles über
einen kamm scheren
kann weil ich einfach glaube dass es
regionen gibt da besteht keine gefahr
weil dort keine ahnung so keine party
kultur herrscht wie zum beispiel in
berlin wo er glaube ich die
infektionszahlen einfach größer sind ich
glaube es ist schon was dran dass wir
aufpassen müssen aber ich glaube wir
können es eben nicht komplett einmal
über die komplette bundesrepublik mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren